act like we could play guitar but none
of us could but let's see if t-pain
cannot rift over here
[Music]
oh oh the pink is in there okay
all right
you guys stretch that pinky
did we calibrate this i don't think we
calibrated this
got you quicker
[Music]
who made this
[Music]
that's not that's not gonna
we didn't calibrate this i don't think
we calibrated this
[Music]
the number one enemy of every guitar
player
see the the bad thing is i can play real
guitar and this is not helping me at all
oh i'm off
yeah this is not going to work
this is not going to work it's not going
to work
don't
gotta say you look great though
didn't couldn't get that at all
[Music]
it's my pancake i'm terrible at pinkish
stuff
you see what i did there it's a family
job
that pinky stretch is hard even when it
comes to keyboard uh keyboards that's
why i changed it
yo i know guys that play with only two
fingers what yeah see now okay now
you're just trying to embarrass me
that's
ah
what is this what
oh come on oh come on come on
okay i don't even know my own song
anymore you know sorry like the way he's
moving his fingers he barely picks his
fingers up
[Music]
this
ridiculous like butter butter over there
this
is
[Music]
oh that actually works i've never
actually done that before
oh nice
[Music]
i don't even know i i can't wrap my head
around
this these splits these are crazy
but listen more importantly this shows
the different kind of skill sets that it
takes to play all different kinds of
games i know a lot of times when we talk
about gaming we always check out mobas
or fps
or battle royales but this in itself
this this this is ridiculous this is a
lie this is this is out of control i
think this is an act of violence this is